[Applause]
BAM came flying in like Superman
let's--oh had no idea this is a bust out
dribble right off the glass he coasted
to slow down and here comes BAM with a
spectacular play Bucks were seemingly
shocked by this the Hawks defense
keeping a minute diandra hunter the
rookie from Virginia had his duck be
railed by the long arm of BAM Adebayo
they had coming out of nowhere and again
able to clip it without fouling we see
this note line up on the floor here for
Atlanta yes Leonard inside of B Andre
hunter this is Tyler Johnson and now
Devin Booker against none into the paint
by damn who protected the rim perfectly
two seconds left in the half of three we
cam
young players would have caught this and
gone right up and had a contact
excellent ball fake great pivot gets him
even more space away from Drummond so
that he doesn't have to worry about the
big guy getting back in the picture is
more the prototype quicker the 61 rookie
from Vanderbilt as a batsman is tonight
like BAM atta boy what a block right at
the rim it's BAM again hard cut to the
basket Jimmy finding him heat rolling
here at their house
[Applause]
confirmation if this shot got off in
time and eat nation you're gonna know at
first that's good great next is a huge
type of belief in your skill set but he
still believes it's his job to make them
as well as tick them he understands the
space and room that it provides just the
mere fact that he is such a threat to
have some sort of rebounding balance
underneath where you might come up with
him ma'am on a quick catch and go move
and then you want to come over and help
you better bring your luggage cuz this
guy right here will Pike it on your head
he is just so athletic and strong he to
score Jones jr. for three
ferocious done for a top I oh it's a
three-point game eight straight points
for the magic they lead by 13 with a 22
left bam underneath against Bamba
Oh over the seven footer Moe poppers a
will power done for BAM attaboy
this is just pure physicality look at
the that's on a seven footer a guy
taller than him has to push him out of
the way pivot and then he'd have to get
up higher on that pick-and-roll take
away that turn BAM underneath with a
reverse Jam another defensive mix-up for
Brooklyn but 22 points again I don't
care how you get him he's still getting
well he's shooting a high percentage
he's efficient
[Applause]
better slam for bail that is just for to
tip open look at this Boulder tapping to
help and that sets up the LOB activity
excellent one hand catch with that big
steal and a half a game
there's kendrick nerve lobbing preparing
a crushing gun the most important to
hook up to the game
with him to training us the passes
behind him he had to go back with his
offhand and Chorale it in it's got to be
quick
[Music]
laughs same page right here he fakes the
pass and goes right over the top and
rented BAM for crate in the space from
Cory Joseph there they didn't put a
longer player on BAM which is surprising
they switched and that allowed the heat
to go over the top and for drunk it's
put that Paul in perfect position they
chose to put length on draaga CH instead
of on BAM Adebayo
and that's what allowed so heroin green
with 11 points a piece off the bench to
leave the Clippers in story
Florida MO Harkless just couldn't get to
I mean what a finish right there BAM
[Applause]
one of six beyond the arc at seven for
gays their leading scorer BAM already
has two triple buckles this year
BAM slam at an 82-game season last year
hook with the 25 he's had up until today
19 and 6
[Applause]
this is errand boy coming that dragon
[Applause]
that is the best defensive play of the
game he's coming on the gyro it's a
slower move and then BAM is able to swat
it off Gordon right there it should be
good from start to finish
Jimmy Butler who played with the Sixers
last year twenty three points again
which sounds good but it's four and a
half points per game in less than he
averaged last year's BAM throws them
there with the ball fake and then got to
the left hand laying the dick decide to
give up Marcus Morrison who goes to one
of the two la teams that is fascinating
that's the other thing is there's a lot
and a bio from Goran Dragic as the heat
has opened up the 12 point lead 17 point
lead for them it was a two-point
Sacramento lead at the half
and out of bio eruption all it looked
like bowling pins inside watch the three
kings just scatter as he finishes on top
of the basket unbelievable power and
athleticism with the crusher let go
barren jail and threw away the key
there it is Jam of the game over the two
time defensive legend don't expect him
with BAM he showed us athleticism and
the ability to rebound and finish at the
rim
but now he's actually running their
offense and doing things like that first
check in tonight gets it back from BAM
three on the shot clock
babe leaning in and scoring halfway
through the third quarter deflection
loose ball picked up by junior babe
[Applause]
opportunity to run out it's that long
arm of Derek Jones initial contact and
bam gets a hand on it and boy those are
the kind of run out opportunities you
want his two career games over 20 points
both this year he scored 25 for
Louisville season at the Clippers
- of a shock rock band buries George
[Applause]